ecco
[Musica]
dico a te
chi è qui in alto
ancora tu
ti sei divertito
all
togliendo ho visto storie bene
per far ridere capitoli
lancerò una crostata
questo è tutto vero
lo so
[Musica]
fisico
ma adesso è il momento di proroga
ma i due benvenuti alla prontezza
ragazzi siamo qui con noi hanno che
voleva fare la presentazione al posto
mio
allora vedo che ti sei vestito tutto in
tiro io sto col pantaloncino della pippa
ma è questo il vero senso di prorompenza
venite con quello che avete sarà un
allenamento molto difficile un risveglio
della forza un risveglio muscolare me
l'hai chiesto
beh voluto tosto l'avete voluto tosto
che l'avrete posto vuol dire qualcosa
una domanda che vuol dire un rischio di
muscolare vuol dire che attiva un mostro
metabolismo che si è scordato pure come
la chiami prima di cominciare però fare
dei ringraziamenti soprattutto alla
palestra che ci sta ospitando gabriele
puoi fare tu giorno il caso è sì che
quasi sono di casa
ma ora la vanity veloce vogliamo
ringraziare solamente la palestra
vertigo qui a ciampino se potete
informarvi sui vari corsi che hanno vi
lasciamo qui dell'info box il loro link
ha detto ciò partiamo subito prima di
iniziare collegamento con il
riscaldamento gabriele ha confezionato
per voi un riscaldamento fatto ad hoc
dovrebbe comparire un link qua sopra
quindi cliccate e ci vediamo fra
pochissimo ma non è che sta allenando a
gabriele stanno facendo di riscaldare
spingo bene con il bacino e l'ha fatto
ha fatto il fatto se avete fatti
riscaldamento buon per voi ritenete di
farmi del male se non aver fatto sti
cavoli chiediamo una sola vita ragazzi
oggi faremo questo tipo di allenamento
corpo libero lo possiamo fare anche da
casa senza bisogno di attrezzi molto
molto intenso
no non l'ho provato quindi non so magari
due io uccido riattiveremo il nostro
metabolismo a tenere due minuti intensi
di lavoro con quattro esercizi diversi
quindi 30 secondi trenta secondi di
recupero altri due minuti con altri
quattro esercizi 30 secondi di recupero
gli altri due minuti con altri quattro
esercizi tutti per voi
un cazzo poi abbiamo un minuto e mezzo
di pausa e ricominciamo per non mi
sembra questo l'atteggiamento devono che
voleva tenere questo atteggiamento
pazzesco partiamo fra 10 qualcosa 9 con
portiamo sulle ginocchia pronti per 30
secondi 3 2 1 che porta sulle ginocchia
sorridendo ancora per poco ancora per
poco sorrido giugliano e già distrutto e
già ristretto di alloggiava più va bene
importiamo portiamo portiamo da tv di
gli schiaffetti sentite di corteggiate
vi schiena dritta porto su chiuso sul
legno tu sei bello con le scarpe felice
pronti allora penso che abbiamo fatto
una cazzata
abbiamo fatto già un minuto nono eccolo
eccolo 30 secondi via cambio da qui
presto basso porto una gamba indietro
porto l'altra gamba dietro e sorrido 30
secondi vado qui che guardo il
cronometro
ok ok importanti non ti alzare non fare
il bar collino resta qui in basso qui
guardami guardami sto qui resto qui il
ginocchio sfiora terra sfiora terra
ritorno signora terra e ritorno via non
mi pare parlare perché tosto via pronti
un minuto minuto cambio via uno squat
yalp è uno squat normale via 30 secondi
ho trovato ritmo cioè che sia poco da
ospedale via ferrini bruciamo le gambe
vai anche voi da casa forza su uno squat
normale e una già uno squat normale è
una jump sentita quanto brucia pronti i
cambi
vengo tenuta si macchino sperando di
ritenuta non sta spiega allora ginocchia
bello e fuori le ginocchia
perpendicolari dall'allusione schiena
dritta
tengo 15 secondi trattengo non apro non
apro resto il resto resto resto 10 98
via 7 6 5 3 2
uno stop 30 secondi trenta secondi stai
pronto sei pronto allora adesso facciamo
un planck side by side
non so se si chiama così chiare le fatti
i cazzi e potrebbe chiamarsi così fra 15
secondi partiamo attenzione preparate il
coro andiamo giù pronti 10 7
ognuno molto tempo in un nuovo tool
ritmo andiamo insieme una via da qui
side by side side by side side by side
occhio che ve lo date pure da soli e
pronti ap la bravissimo lui erano via
via si vede adesso prodotti
321 cambio monta spingo ginocchia porta
davanti che sono un principiante come
fare un cavo lan che tenete bene la
linea spalle cadono sulle braccia e
sulle mani legate via via via ota quanto
brucia pronti 21 cambio via planck 30
secondi ma è lo senti metabolismo che ti
dice valentino metabolico questo
allenamento quando ho fatto venire a
mauro all'istruttore l'ho fatto ma lui
c'è una cosa da pazzi
pensavo fosse norma non approvato
scusami non l'ho provata ti chiedo scusa
mi chiedo scusa anche la casa pronti
via cambio allora vado qui quando qui
rotolo dietro tocco mi posso anche
aiutare per rialzare piegamento via via
via se volete mi aiuto piegamento vado
dietro si 10 secondi mai chi lo faceva
lo vedi è una culla è una culla un buon
rizzolo è un codec con loro ed è una
bulla guarda guardami guardami cazzo 30
secondi come come stai alla grande
esagerato guarda leggo tutti i commenti
benissimo voti va bene questo è così che
aiuta seri touch 3a portiamoli jumping
jack 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 via basterà un qui a
come questo
no no no no perfetto perfetto che
rendeva più like per la cdt
ma perché sì perché se ne scusa già qui
in jack o no celo celo solette cambio o
cambio ti spiego da qui parte orologio
rilevamento stacco le braccia giro
orologio stacco le braccia mai stato
ritorno stacco ritorno stacco ritorno
sacco ritorno stacco grido di via cambio
cambio cambio partito che ci abbiamo in
jam club a noi lo facciamo un gelato dai
è meglio che si fece più anni 90
come ti senti
e poi l'ultimo che c'abbiamo mi
ricordano adesso vediamo pronti 30 via
da qui
scendo giù porto su via subito porto su
porto su porto su porto su una palestra
enorme guarda come ci siamo ridotti
appiccicati via uno sopra l'altro forza
guardate pagina 10 secondi via gli
ultimi momenti
coop casa riposiamo recupero attivo
el scorsi regala recupero attivo
rihanna ti piaccio scopo parlare è
tostissima solo scorsi avevo detto un
minuto e mezzo di recupero è molto
faticoso ma si tanto siamo venuti qua
fermo
adesso in tratta volino con il tempo e
biscotti le signore nesbitt bevi invece
di fare ste cagate sto mettendo sto
scorso
ok detto senza casa che siamo pronti
voglio fare un nuovo no look per il ha
così tiene no così dovrebbe tenere ok
siamo pronti siamo quante 23 giu
non serve a niente questo caso per me lo
ritroverò sopra il microfono non mi
interessa ma che ti sei perso qualcosa
in questi ultimi mesi ti sei messo
qualcosa perché con il tuo così si trova
subito
l'inter ha vinto lui vuole girare
l'intro dopo l'allenamento pentole
william non sarà sulla barella che entra
a fare il treno si ok ma siamo pronti 10
secondi stesse cose che abbiamo fatto
adesso ricordiamo a ricapitolare devorah
capito che cazzo stai lì a 10 adesso non
ti voglio più sentire parlare e non ti
sentirò infatti pronti 65 43
già proprio sorridere mai a cavallo ma
adesso lo so perché sono mai chiesto non
veneto un fianco vogliono da noi che
sono un peso film ma dai calandosi netti
magari no righetti sono monica ok 30
scusa
36 il cambio cambio cambio tavola tavola
giu minimo non toccare qui che stronzo
questa faccia di culo ma solo via via
via ma di tenere via via vengono a
posizione la regata si non si può come
ne vado via cambio uno squat e uno
scocciata buono perché la scusa per
sistemarmi il microfono non te ne fotte
un cazzo cuociano così ginocchio in
fuori ne ho più fuori uscendo bene non
supero con le ginocchia la muta dei
piedi via vado su riuscendo riatterra
composto via faccio vedere anche di
profilo cambio tenuta guarda così in
camera pare così soffre in silenzio io
ho fatto dell'evento di pallavolo ieri
ma questo è un collarino 15 13 12
allenamento di più del 54 32 st recupero
30 secondi e mi preparo mi preparo ai 20
secondi per pregare li vuoi sfruttate
ricordiamo adesso cosa side by side
montand flanders anche a 30 secondi e
godric's hollow la culla 3 2 1 o side by
side morbido cerca di non caricare
troppo i polsi cioè se gli stai troppo
sopra con le spalle in avanti ottima
sincronia via via via via mamiani e
cambio cambio campionando della sera
thunders via
chi io ce l'ho perfetto mi avverte non
dice un cazzo cronometro il tempo ma è
normale rubare un po via climbers ok
anche da casa non ti vedo 10 9 5 4 3 2 1
blanc si viene dato tutto chissà se si
sentirà da juncker nardò per lei ti stai
spaccando il culo tu e non penserà
troppo quella con la macchina da presa
sulla fotocamera
quando manca il 5 4 3 2 1 con il solo mi
ha dato indietro rotolo ritorno avanti e
piegamento godric's hollow dietro torna
avanti e piegamento via pietro tornati
piegamento bria
via cinque secondi cus bari e cap che
recupera 30 secondi mi sembra evidente
ok non piangere davanti a rete reale
gina di almeno questi casi c'è lo
specchio non ti preoccupare gli organi
che la forma il mio bene tra otto
secondi 76 allora cento inzaghi pronto
via attiviamo questo il momento dove si
lavora di più ora che si stanca
guarda che ti faccio ora che si ora che
si stanco dai ora ora è a via via si che
abbiamo ancora un botto ce l'abbiamo con
un blocco tranquilli ragazzi è quasi un
morto e quasi finire un cazzo c'è ancora
un botto ragazzi però c'è poco da fare
qui a modane quasi hai finito qua li ha
dati
pagliaro locci orologio piegamento
stacco torna su
stacco le braccia di stato le braccia
ritorno sul palco le braccia ritorno su
ragazzi così non si può lavare non è ma
almeno mi dai spazio leva di mourinho mi
ha chiamato dai ok cambio casa cambio da
dove semplice a torino dove è qui ei
ragazzi tranquilli c'è ancora una sede
via fatti vedere felice pronto cambio
side by side ce l'ho chiamato così da
qui guarda la mia mano casti ti infila
dentro capiti capiti
castiglione dopo paris 2d può uno di qua
e uno col pene laterale così 10 secondi
via
ci siamo quasi stop un milione e mezzo
doveva facciano così non si può certo si
gira e io sto fermo microfoni perché
comprarli ma da teloni collo e tutto
sfumato sono sudato vuol dire che sto
sporcando tante possibile stante
inettitudini fai un perizoma dal culo
che risale sopra e lo attacchi qui al
codino così fai pure una parola ma così
non ne posso muovere così come ci sono
una tartaruga quanto abbiamo di recupero
è una festa come ti senti fisicamente le
gambe che pensi che ti regalano al banco
dei salumi art o di queste queste dei
file mica stanno sconto esposizione
mediatica su auto cia regala tar todis
secondo lui ci saranno altri allenamenti
ci sarà di tutto e io spero di abbandono
il prima possibile questo accendimi bene
chi mi ha spinto il pm che poi bello lo
sai che se adesso noi compriamo
microfono bono loro agente modaiolo
scorso il peso e quindi è finita io così
per sempre ragazzi fateci sapere se
volete un microfono buono o scotch
ok siamo pronti non temporeggiamo perché
dove fare altro si 10 9 8 7 6 lo
conosciamo già i 21 gol via siamo
ripartiti
pensa che la prima volta che lo fa e che
c'è dopo è invece tu sei già porca [ __ ]
via dai tutto ragazzi è importante
adesso che è l'ultimo dare tutto se ci
siamo conservati come guglielmo che
faceva le cose
davamo tutto l arte queste ginocchia mai
neanche crociato anche croce nato via
via via 321 cambio giu resto a tavoletta
resto a tavoletta anche fatto piano ma
resto qui non mi alzo questi oro col
ginocchio vado giù per questo oro col
ginocchio il vado giù
questo è un buco di culo sì tutto via
dieci secondi via via via via 532 uno
stop
scoccia e stop mia è una via e 2 e 3 e 4
socket ossa ragazzi brucia tutto andiamo
avanti dai falli più piano ma fallì mia
di cazzo mi ha tenuta teniamo teniamo fa
brucia tutto brucia tutto è normale
brucia tutto guardiamo guardiamo il
nostro obiettivo
vai vai siamo già a metà tempo metà
tempo 13 12 10 9 7 6
i tre due uno stop che brucia tutto vai
vai ricorse 30 secondi pensava coloro
metti riposo per 20 19 concentrati
concentrati concentrati e pronti
andiamo con il planck side by side fra
10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 via blind side by
side via dai stringiamo i denti
spingiamo i denti ok pop la copla la
parte delle gambe in bici diane
devastanti sai dopo che gli spot quale
hanno appoggiato piani sì certo
mihai bloccato una nota ieri via dai dai
dai
ci siamo 15 10 5 4 2 1 punk mai le
giuste su bene la spalla cade sul vomito
ma un ottavo lato cervicale e rilassata
anche con tutto lo scotch sto morendo
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai ti guardo ai
migliori futuro 7
321 godric's godric's hollow trovatolo
ritorno e piegamento rotolo ritorno il
piegamento rotolo dai è fatto solo 30
secondi di recupero sia via scatto
recupera so cosa questa ammazzato guarda
come mi sono ridotto io
cioè fare una copertina così con cui
siamo in ginocchio
capita allora jumping jack 21 via work
vai vai diamo tutto eh sì perché se non
è mentalmente no sai se lo possono fare
si può uscire 54 bayern sto cambio un
orologio via vado giro ci possiamo
queste non c'entriamo fidati leggo le
braccia ritorno 1 bevo le braccia
ritorno due le braccia di turno la
coordinazione passano le braccia passano
le gambe
passano le braccia possa negare via
ancora in via questo mi piace
allenamento metabolico quello di
schiacciati piedino 10 secondi prima
così ragazzi facciamo è datata di tutto
un fuoco
chi viaggia via ultimi 30 secondi risi
lettera mia e castighi qui a e castità
via e casti ti passo capiti passo casti
ci passo casti di da dieci secondi dai
tutto
dai tutto ultimo guardan ok goielli
guglielmo tufara tre puntate è la
reazione a catena per ripristinare la
muscolatura per recuperare le nostre
forze che allenarci anche domani o anche
dopodomani è importante recuperare con
lo stretching spingo e adesso lo lascio
giu vada spinge non si capisce un cazzo
con questa cosa in testa
scusate non lo mutate questo pezzo sennò
capiscono che non sono un vecchio che
dire ragazzi a parte gli scherzi
abbiamo fatto un allenamento molto molto
tosto complimenti guglielmo che era da
tanto che non si allenava
complimenti anche a me a noi perché i
ragazzi effettivamente era molto molto
complete
completano complete volevo dire
complicati proprio brinkley promptly ok
floro flores lì in esposizione mediatica
dei regalato 18 capire subito ragazzi
chiede a questo canale mettete un po le
censure mi piace il format di gabriele
pro compensa affatto semplice cos'altro
vorreste vedere all'interno di questo
format cos'è che vorreste visionare
vorreste bruciare grassi vorrei sapere
un culo prorompente vorreste avere una
vita migliore una vita migliore in
generale qua sotto
noi ci vediamo domenica con una puntata
di così una puntata che risolviamo i
problemi di chi sono i problemi
ciao ragazzi ciao a tutti